[Music]
we're here with Robbie Russell founder
co-founder of Planet argon Studios and
creator of the very popular oh my
zsh uh open source repository and Tool
yeah thanks thanks for having me joining
us from beautiful Portland Oregon uh his
adopted home yeah I've been here for
20 what year is it 20 2024 oh my gosh uh
it'll be 24 years in uh July I guess
that I moved here so yeah more half of
my life now yeah and uh originally from
California G yeah I grew up in yeah just
south of uh like Silicon Valley my dad
worked in Silicon Valley and hardware
and we lived in a little small suburb
town that was kind of on the edge of
very Southern there's like I don't
remember if it's actually the furthest
south town in Santa clar County but yeah
it's um it's kind of like at the time is
very
farmland and you know track houses and
stuff like that and so was maybe about
an hour and a half or so South of San
Francisco and maybe 45 minutes south of
San Jose yeah and uh Gilroy that's like
garlick town right is that is that the
like the world capital of garlic the
crop it likes to call itself that um I
don't know that it's actually where most
of garlic is produced nowadays I think
most of it's actually produced in China
um but yeah there was a huge uh garlic
scene there if you will uh it smelled
like garlic people it's either you loved
it or ha it if you drove through our
town um coincidentally the town just
north of us had had a lot of mushrooms
that they grew and so their Town smell
like poop can I swear on this podcast
smell like but they were like
slightly wealthier town and so there was
this weird competitive thing and like
your town smells you guys are poor down
in gory they made the the the fossi and
bargain yeah our Town's going to smell
terrible but we're going to be slightly
better off than our neighbors exactly um
so yeah I grew up in the garlic Capital
world and all I wanted to do as soon as
I became a teenager was figure out how
to get out of living in gy and move to a
some sort of city Urban environment
that's what I wanted to be around yeah
right on man well uh obviously you found
Portland to be like a a good place to be
because you've been there for like
basically your entire adult life most of
it um you've got like a very um I mean
you're very very portlandian in like
pretty much um your interests and things
that you do you're like very outdoorsy
from what I understand and um yeah like
what what inspired you to go to Portland
specifically and uh it was really cool
by the way hanging out eating tacos with
you it was it was good that we got the
chat and um I didn't I didn't know what
to expect from the conversation and yeah
we had a number of tacos and talked
about all facets of life um with you and
Abby over there at free Cod Camp um
who's become a really good friend
coincidentally um thanks to free code
Camp uh we can talk about that if you
want to but um yeah think about why did
I move to Portland well the short story
is that I didn't know what I wanted to
do with my life my career I didn't have
any like real I was painting houses for
about three years prior to moving
to Portland I I since I was 17 I dropped
out of high school halfway through my
junior year and then ended up getting a
job with like a painting company that my
my one of my uncles worked at and learn
to sand and touch up and eventually
learn how to paint and take care of wood
and paint
roof the things that are on I forget
what they're called flashing flashing
and all the the things flashing gutters
yeah flashing is like the metal stuff
that might be covering like there'll be
like you know air vents on top of a
house anyways I got to learn how to
paint houses for really fancy really
fancy houses in uh Santa Clara County um
like we occasionally work on you know
multi-million dollar houses for people
that work in Silicon Valley or maybe
they were like they they're like um like
one of the players or something from
like the the San Jose Sharks a hockey
team like their big you know big house
they were building up on the hills and
so I got to work on those types of
projects which were not like kind of get
in and get out short projects they were
very much like we would be there for
like a month two months working on
painting and prepping and painting
working as their house was being built
and making nice cabinets and so we would
make paint or cabinets like the big
style at the time was making cabinets
look like they were basically White
plastic even though it was like really
fancy wood I don't such a weird how
Styles change over time quirky in
interior decorating train right so I
learned a lot about like the craft and
how much work went into prepping before
you even pulled the paint out right
before the paint dries and then touching
up and taking care of that stuff um when
I was a teenager after having dropped
out of high school and so that's that's
what I was doing and I'm like I actually
thought I might if you do I think in
California I don't know if it's like
that all states but
before you could start like your own say
painting company if I had I I kind of
had a little bit of aspiration like oh
maybe one day I'll I'll run a painting
company like I think I could probably do
this and have some people maybe work for
me and I'll just work in construction
but that also the reality was it would
mean that I'd be working construction
and I didn't find that you know it's
funny that we talk about diversity in
Tech over the years and I'm like
construction was there was a lot of
cultural diversity um where people were
from and stuff but it was mostly male
dominated and I didn't really like
working with just men all the time and
so I thought that was you know that that
was actually one of the things I thought
it was a very toxic environment as a I
kind of saw myself as this kind of
anarcho uh punk rock kid who was trying
to like you know pushing you know like I
want my gay friends to be able to get
married and like here I'm going to work
every day and everybody's talking in
very conservative and very
male-dominated environment and kind of
objectified women and when whenever we'd
see women on the like the job sites that
was like always like you know there's a
lot of cat calling and stuff and I'm
like this is not an environment that I
feel like I want to spend a lot of time
in um so anyways we that's a whole story
and of itself so I decided I wasn't
going to do that forever and like this
is like I didn't want to work around
that environment forever so uh I wanted
to move to a city and I didn't make very
much money painting and I didn't and I
was like well I was kind of doing some
odd jobs here and there doing some like
tech support stuff and so but the price
to live in Portland was technically
cheaper than it was in Gilroy
interesting and it was like it was a
city that had vegetarian restaurants
like punk rock scene um I can go see
music it felt relatively clean um as a
city in the sense like you walk around
downtown and there' be like you know
some gutter Punk kids and I'm like well
worst case if I don't find a job here I
can just be a gutter Punk kid and get a
dog and just kind of hang around and um
I'll just I'll figure it out I'm just
like maybe kind of glamorized this like
DIY lifestyle and Portland has exuded
that I I would have loved to moved to
Berkeley or Santa San Francisco or Santa
Cruz but I couldn't I couldn't afford
that those are expensive cities to live
in I didn't know it wasn't programming
or anything at that point um much to
speak of anyways um not thinking that
would be a viable thing and the other
part of like wanting to move out of
California was that I felt like
everything was kind of driven towards
hey if you should work in the computer
industry that like my father worked in
Silicon Valley he just retired a couple
months ago he worked in hardware and he
was always like you need to you should
really be interested in software he was
always trying to encourage me to get
interested in software buy me books on
softare I always I always had computers
around I had my very my own computer
which was always like my dad's the one
he basically would grow out of I got the
one he get the he get a 386 I got the
286 he got the 486 I got the 386 and so
it just be I just learned how to work
around with computers a lot as a kids
using them to play games and using some
of the the software that would come on
it making cool
little spreadsheets and stuff like that
or Ms paint or playing weird games on
the you know command line games and
stuff like that but uh I just never
resonated with me like learning how to
programming I just thought it was it it
didn't seem like an interesting thing
for whatever reason it was like because
it was always presented as like hey if
you learn if you write out this code
into this you know this editor thing um
andun run it then you can play the game
and I was like okay so I'd be maybe
typing what it was doing for I get bored
like I've just like you know basically
rewriting something from a book yeah
under the computer I'm like I'm can I go
outside and play with my friends I'm G
to go do that you know this is like can
I just play the game someone already did
it and yeah you're basically doing
rework I mean there was definitely a
time where there just wasn't enough
memory and like it was more practical to
distribute printed copies of the code
and have people type it in themselves
but I'm sure that by the time you were a
kid that that time had passed and it was
more like a an exercise yeah it was more
of the exercise like learning it was
never really presented as like well if
you get it to run and then we can then
change it make different you know modify
it to do something a little differently
let's change like we never had that
conversation so I never that there was
never that little aha moment of like o I
can do something different with it um
and so I wrote a couple blog posts in
the past about like how my my dad failed
to teach me or get me excited about
programming um when I was young and I
think it was just like we're that was
the ingredient that I think I was
missing was like wouldn't it be kind of
neat if we can make something to do X Y
and Z and then let's figure that out
which I think speaks to how I learned
about things and why so so very
practical kind of appli like you don't
seem to me like the person who Geeks out
on technology for the sake of Technology
itself it's all about what can this
technology do for me exactly um
the you know I think if he had you know
I played I played you know Little League
baseball and things like that as a kid
and um so what like I remember I was
really interested in stats for for our
team and so we would track the stats for
our game you know for for all of our
players couple years I would do this and
then I would like and my dad and I would
like put some stuff together in like a
spreadsheet and then like regenerate
this thing and I bring a print out to
the team you'd be like here's your stats
for the season you know like here's your
on based things and your your batting
average and pitching details and so we
could track some of that stuff over time
because uh there wasn't like a web page
or anything that kids this you know this
is all late 80s early 90s yeah period of
time and so if we had had a conversation
like wouldn't it be cool like if we
could build a little tool that maybe
every week you come back from the game
and like plug in the new numbers and
then it would regenerate the report or
something like that probably would have
I probably would have that would have
resonated I think really well with me
but it was that wasn't what we did we we
learned I got to learn how to use
spreadsheets and stuff like that I think
it was like Lotus 123 or something back
then but so I still got to learn how to
use the tools that you could use and you
know like build spreadsheets and stuff
like that and coincidentally another
thing my dad kind of encouraged was we
were always bu building our own
computers so we would go buy all the
parts and then we put it together and so
I learned how to do that with him and I
became like this weird thing where he
would kind of show off to his friends
because they would want to get a
computer and maybe they weren't they
didn't work in the computer industry
um that's I'm just going to say the
computer because that's how I refer to
it that's how my dad and people referred
to it like oh they work in computers
that's kind of what we said like now
it's like everybody works in now we use
like we work in Tech and that's a weird
yeah thing to call it as well but the
there was this like we' build it and
then we like you know maybe a neighbor
would get their first computer and then
I I would be then sent over for a week
or two every couple couple like maybe an
hour a couple times a week to teach them
how to do stuff on it and so be like
here show them how to like open up Word
Perfect or how to use the spreadsh thing
or how to teach the kids how they can
start the games themselves you know and
put the floppy thing in here's how to
install it but then here's some
shortcuts you can add to your DOS prompt
to like here's the commands you you you
run to like launch you know to play
Commander Keen or something and so that
became something like I kind of was good
at maybe teaching people how to do
things like it um and showing them like
well if you know if my dad's kid kid
could figure this out I could probably
figure it out you know like so I was
kind of paraded around in that sort of
way like some of the so it sounds like
the fact that your dad was you know
encouraging you and that you had
Hardware on hand I mean uh that you did
have kind of like
uh what many people would call like like
uh an ideal kind of
like um ground soil for growing as a
potential developer in growing up around
the tools uh having somebody in your
life who was already making a living
from these tools and and that kind of
seed the seeds of later on when you were
you know considering your options uh
potentially getting more into computers
maybe you could talk a little bit about
that that period where you wanted to go
into business and pot you you were
ambitious you wanted to have uh a
company that was potentially going
around painting but you you weren't like
in love with the kind of construction
work culture will what what did you do
how did you go about uh ultimately
creating a consultancy like what what
was the uh process in between those two
points there's there's a couple of
factors and you know I haven't really
spent a lot of time reflecting on this
specific point but I feel like in this
conversation is kind of highlighting
something that
I you know earlier I mentioned that I
kind of was I I in during that same time
that I was painting I was obs obsessed
with DIY punk rock culture East Bay East
Bay Port um and East Bay um in the Bay
Area in California uh it was like a lot
of punk bands came out of that area
there was like a lot of small record
companies that were like it was just
like kids that were maybe four to five
years older than me had running record
labels selling stickers through
cataloges and I started one my my very
first business was a sticker company and
it was like Punk stickers.com and I was
like I'm going to oh you had punk
stickers.com you had that domain did I
did pretty good domain um and then I
lost it and I recently just negotiated
buying it again but I don't know what
I'm going to do with that uh we'll see
um but the idea was like I wanted to
sell stickers for bands and and make and
also political activist stickers and
there was someone up in but so I like
looked up to these people that had I we
go to like anarchus Book Fairs in San in
San Francisco and stuff and like people
were like all these self-published
people that were writing books and Zen
and so I had a Zen as well and I was
like for like music related stuff and I
was like I was just really fascinated
with this idea that like there's I was
finding a community people that were
kind of kind of content creators selling
like their Wares but kind of being a
little you know just doing your doing it
yourself and not wanting to work for
someone else it was more like I'm going
to go find my own thing and I think that
was very much a an ethos of that era
with like indie film you know was like
people like I think I would like I would
have loved to I just wanted to do
something interesting and I what you
know I thought was interesting and
creative that I can kind of build my own
destiny and not end up working my
biggest fear was ending up in a cubicle
in Silicon Valley I'm like that's my
intive with computer industry was I'll
be working in a cubicle somewhere there
will be Windows way down a
hallway um far far away and not that you
know I I go to my dad's my dad worked in
hardware and specifically in hard um
hard drive manufacturing yeah and so I
would go to the I would go to work with
them every once in a while which I
enjoyed cuz I would get this meet all
these interesting people from all walks
of life and people coding and and going
in like the the the clean rooms and
stuff and seeing stuff how stuff was
built but there was but I was like there
was something about that lifestyle for
whatever reason I don't I don't know if
I was like subjected to some maybe it
might have just been like punk rock
music and being just like rebelling and
like I don't want to do what you want me
to do dad which was probably to get a
safe job in Silicon Valley like my
grandfather did my grandfather worked at
like he worked in Tech as well like was
a traveling consultant and worked at
like Atari early on and like so there's
like I always had like that was
like that was like my legacy of like
this is what you're supposed to do and I
was like that I want to go do I
want to go kind I want to be a musician
I'm going to make stickers I going to do
my own thing um which I think was even
like when I thought about being a
painter and having my own company was
more like I feel like someone else is
making money off of my time why don't I
just go do this myself and I don't know
that I thought a lot about building a
company that would have employees
necessar so that was like that
definitely cuz I I think I was always
skeptical of people in power you know in
leadership positions and so I think
there was a there was a little bit of
that and so uh which I think comes back
to the how Planet argon started in the
early years of I'm trying to think how
to th thread the needle there because
I'm kind of going back a little bit
there but there's yeah but going to
Portland was very much a hey I want to
I'm going to go see if I can make it and
do something on my own and ended up
coincidentally my first job in Portland
was a job in a cubicle doing tech
support for a couple so you got a taste
of like your your greatest fear
essentially um just like like
circumstance propelled you into a
situation where you couldn't deny your
destiny as an IT worker as a Dilbert
character indeed uh exactly Dilbert
character uh I was obsessed with Dilbert
back then
um
but and then that show so during that
period of time where I'm doing it
support for about 200 people in the
company and I started to you know
basically a lot of going around help
people fix their stuff that was problems
on their computer um setting up new
machines because we were hiring a bunch
of people you know that's doing you know
part of the onboarding and and and
helping people upgrade their systems but
people would come with a lot of similar
questions you know things and I was like
oh it'd be really easy if I just created
like this I had already started making
we pages and stuff like that for like my
sticker company for my zen and some
other like little personal projects and
some for for some bands and stuff like
that and so I was learning how to build
some web pages because I wanted to my
first entry into programming kind of
like really doing anything like web
based was like being able to I wanted
people to make a request to order some
stickers and so I'm like well how do I
build a web page and so I figured out
how to like I couldn't I was going to
pay someone to build me like a form that
could collect data from people and so I
I learned how to maybe do something with
like I remember if it was Microsoft
front page or something eventually I
learned how to do it in like with some
CGI scripts with pearl so I was like
just picking up some books I'm like how
do I have like a form saved to like a
CSV file or a text file and I can FTP
that file down and see if anyone ordered
any new stickers um
and that that was like my entry into
kind of doing a little bit of
programming but it was because I wanted
to sell stickers so how do I make that
happen and so that those types of skills
start to slowly start to accumulate so
by the time I'm um actually at this job
doing text support and I'm helping
people I start putting together some web
pages like on an internet um because I
knew how to like spin up like a Linux
server and run what what year was this
approximately uh that job I moved to
Portland in 2000 so that was like you
know fall winter of 200000 um I was
starting to do some of that stuff and so
so that
company you know they they were an event
management company and so we did I was
helping people do a lot of like CSV or
Excel file dding stuff and like so I'm
like here's like I could build like a
little script to help out with some of
these CSV D duping things I started
making like tutorials where it' be like
a bunch of screenshots so like here's
how to set your out of out of office
Auto repes so it doesn't create an
infinite loop with someone else that
also is on vacation that can be uh
problematic that used to happen back
then on email servers um but so they
there was the company started to notice
that I was doing this and there was
another department of the company that
was actually like a web development team
for our custo like the company's
customers and they're like hey why are
you doing all this web stuff like why
aren like that should be us that's doing
they were kind of like a little bit like
why are you so was like territorial a
little bit and then and in 2001 they
they announced some layoffs and then I
did not get laid off but then they
called me and do they're like hey if you
want to keep your if you want to stay
working here we have a role we think you
could be a junior web developer for us
because you're already doing some of
this stuff so would you consider moving
over to this other department and I was
like oh I get to just do that stuff all
the time and not have to go around
people's computers and and like and like
do I get to keep work and and you can
get to keep working on the internet
because everybody started to really like
it and um that was a whole thing of like
I remember them even thinking like it
was like a new idea for them and it was
only because I just started doing it and
I was like ah I'm just going to make
this to make my job easier and here's a
link you can solve this problem yourself
now um so I moved to the the web team
and so personally I was like learning
how to do some stuff with pearl and PHP
but the company they weren't going to
touch any open source stuff like that
they were all using Microsoft um ASP
back then net had I don't think it had
just come out I remember going to the
net launch though with that team but so
they so during the day I was learning
how to do stuff with Microsoft SQL
server and kind of learning they're
basically putting me on these repetitive
projects where I was spinning up these
like complex registration forms for
these events and I would then go home
and like well how do I apply what I
learned at work today in this other
technology stuff that I'm way more
excited about which was like open source
because it was all that open source
World resonated with a DI iy mentality
there was a lot of you know free stuff
out there I could just download and spin
up a website really quickly for some
project for a band or for some activist
project I was being a part of and so I I
was kind of doing this like my
Moonlighting thing was I'm doing open
source stuff at night having fun with
you know trying to learn how to Tinker
with things and building my own projects
and then uh and building some really
really horrible like PHP minus schl
things and if anyone really went down
the rabbit hole and searched me on
Source Forge you could find some
probably embarrassing code there that
was probably security written and should
not be run anywhere but it was running
at my company on their internet they
would allow me to use the open source
stuff for the internet stuff but not on
our client work that was too risky um to
go into that t but anyway so Planet
argon started in 2002 as me saying you
know what because I started realizing I
was I was building up all the skill set
and people started asking me like hey
will you work on this project for my
business like I have a consulting
company where I do this thing and can
you build me a website that I and I was
like well yeah I can do that but but I'm
going to I will only do it if I can
build some functionality that you allow
you to make changes for yourself like a
CMS type tool or something so that you
don't have to call me every time you
want to like change some copy on your
website um because I don't I don't want
to do that you know yeah that's like the
the first evolution as a freelancer is
like you you realize oh no I'm these
calls are never going to go away like
exact there will always the updates
needed made I need to figure out a
process essentially of like delegating
the change back to the client exactly so
that's that's kind of how that the
Consulting part started so
2002 is when Planet oron created as this
thing and and coincidentally my partner
at the time she was a designer and so so
she and I uh girlfriend at the time we
so we would occasionally work up on work
on projects together and so the so the
day like I remember sitting there in our
apartment we were talking through like
hey let's she already had like a design
thing so she was doing design work with
some clients and that would be like
print and web based digital stuff like
brochures and things that she would do
and I've had this programming skill set
and like okay maybe we can collaborate
on some projects so I had my business
and she had her business um but she was
there the day that like Planet Aron
started and like touched almost she did
the first website designed my first
business card she was there when we
talked through all the different bit U
naming ideas and before we came up with
the idea for Planet argon and how that
came to be own story but yeah yeah what
is the story behind that so so I like uh
so for a long time I would make it be
kind of a mystery and I would always
give this book to my employees I don't
know if You' ever heard of the author um
Tom Robbins by chance I haven't uh he's
pretty well known in the Pacific
Northwest he wrote like even cowg girls
get the blues and there one of his books
called still life with woodpecker and
it's about an
anarchist um terrorist coincidentally
but and like an ex princess who fall in
love with each other um and there's this
whole he has anyways he the the main
character is a redhead and there's the
way the the the author is very Kurt vona
esque in some ways but he'll have these
like chapters where he goes off and
these big random rants about or
ramblings about things that are
completely unrelated to the story but
anyway I love this book when I was like
you know late teenager and Planet argon
there was this like Back stories about
where like the pyramids came from was
actually there's a theory that like it
came from the redbeards which uh like
redheads with their technology because
they were sent away from this other
planet sent to planet Earth because they
were obnoxious human beings and so they
were redheads were so went not visually
seeing this conversation I I have red
hair so plan discriminating against your
own essentially uh Planet argon is where
red heads came from According to this
book as like a kind of like quirky
little Side Story thing um because they
were obnoxious and the people there did
not want redheads there and I don't
blame them we're we're horrible so
anyhow interesting so so it's not Rel
like because I think I've heard you ask
uh in the past maybe on the your podcast
like what's your favorite noble
gas you'd think it would be
argon and you know we've had I think
maybe four or five phone calls or a
company people trying to
purchase argon and so i' always wonder
if that was the business I should have
went into but uh really like people
people want to buy the actual yeah gas
for industrial us maybe Planet argon
sales argon uh no we don't but neon's my
favorite noble gas like that just some
cool stuff but argon I've seen some
really cool use of it um there's a like
a children's uh science museum museum
here in Portland Oregon that they have a
bunch of stuff in the show how different
gases look and so there's some cool
stuff with argon as well and so it can
look it can look pretty cool I don't
know a lot about all the noble gases
admittedly when we had early on in plan
Aron when we had when we start we have
employees and we were offering hosting
services and we had all of our own
servers in Iraq all of our servers were
named after noble gases and and it was
like Xenon and argon and neon and so I
have uh there there's yeah you run out
pretty quick though you do you do so we
had to like kind of like go a little bit
outside of that and eventually we're
like let's just we're we're running out
of noble gases maybe we should stop
doing hosting as a business anyways I
don't want to have to touch physical
Hardware anymore on than yeah yeah and
um so let's talk a little bit about like
the great middle because I think a lot
of people create a consultancy and it's
just them and maybe their significant
other a few friends and it is fine and
it provides a livelihood for the people
involved but you've done something
different in that you've stuck with it
for a long period of time I'm I'm sure
you've had lots of opportunities to go
work at Big Tech and do stuff like that
but but you've kind of stuck to running
this consultancy and growing this
consultancy um and I'd like to hear
about the growth and how you managed to
grow it and what what that process was
like and maybe some of the pain points I
I can definitely interject with the
other questions I'm going to step back
and just kind of hear what what were
those first few years a growth like for
you yeah well the first few years there
was like no growth uh uh so 2002 is when
I started as a you know the Moonlighting
type of thing where I worked on some
projects here and there um you know it
was just enough to have to file taxes
you know um but I was I still had a job
you know full a day job and then I ended
up working actually briefly at a another
consultancy that actually got that
worked in open source specifically and
they're they were known for being
experts in post Rescue all and so I was
I went there for about a maybe a year
and a half or so and it was like and
that was was a pretty small company of
like less you know there was maybe four
or five of us consistently and I was
like you know what I think maybe I could
do this on my it was like again that
like kind of like uh naive kid that's
just kind of like you know at the time
I'm like 23 thinking I could probably do
this I'm doing all the project
management I'm doing the coding like
working with the clients I'm like I kind
of get this I kind of understand and I'm
like I want to maybe work with different
some different technology tools so I I
quit that so I can do Planet earon
full-time so that was uh early 2004 is
when I officially was I'm out on my own
um and to to to make plan argon work or
not um the so here's what happens I'm
doing that I'm you know trying to find
work doing primarily PHP some Pearl a
little bit of python work um and I was
really excited about I think PHP 5 was
coming at the time and it was going to
introduce some more o related stuff into
the language and I was like this is
object fored yeah this is what I was uh
kind of I was this is what I want to
work with
and and then I'm also I have a band I'm
playing music at the time um and I was
like I had been in a couple bands to
this whole time as well it's another
thread there but the I late 200 maybe
like November 2004 I'm look I'm always
looking for jobs on Craigslist because
that's where you would find work a lot
of time for like these Contracting
projects so people would be looking for
so i''d be scouring Craigslist in
different major cities across the US
people looking for like I I have this
PHP website I need help you know and
then I might get like you know 20 to a
couple hundred hours worth of
development work out of those contracts
so I would just respond that's that's
how I would def find work was like
things through Craigslist and there
might have been some other websites but
that just one happens to be a top of
mind and then one day in Portland there
was an ad for this company that I was
very well aware of called cdbaby.com oh
yeah and Dereck sers yes so they were
looking for a PHP developer here in
Portland and I couldn't think of
anything more perfectly aligned with
like the DIY here's this person who
started this business where it was
helping independent musicians sell their
CDs online because that's how you did it
back then we you would literally like
you make your CDs and you would send CD
Baby a box of CDs and then they they
would put you in their store and then
they would handle the Fulfillment and
the shipping and so they had a huge
Warehouse you know maybe like four miles
from where I live right now
and I was like I knew that a lot of
people worked there were musicians that
worked in like the full field I'm like
that sounds perfect I'll be a programmer
I'll get to work with musicians I might
make new bandmate friends or this might
open up opportunities and maybe maybe
open up doors for my music because I
wanted to play music that that was
really my dream was like I want to be
like I want to make make it as a
musician and yeah we haven't talked
about that but it was like that was one
of the creative Outlets that I really
started to get into around that era of
my life and
so I emailed you know responded to this
Craig stat and I applied for a job
thinking I'll stop doing this Consulting
work because I have to con I'm finding
work all the time but like if I could
work at CD Baby yeah I'll just stop
doing this yeah so I didn't start
planning thinking like oh it's going to
become this thing I'm going to do for
the next several decades it was like
this is what I can do right now so I can
get by pay myself but and maybe
something interesting will pop up so I
was so I applied you Derek quickly
replied to me and he's like hey let's
chat I he's like can I come to your
house or come can I come to you and
we'll have like a little kind of
informal interview so we did that he he
came over to my house one day like you
know in the morning around probably
around this time of the day and he had I
remember he showed up with a he had
stopped at maybe like Whole Foods or
something and showed up with like a big
little plastic container of pineapple
and he was just eating pineapple 9:00 in
the morning I a bunch of it and he's he
was like I made some tea for him and we
chatted for a couple couple hours about
programming and kind of him getting to
know a bit more about my background as
as a software developer he's like oh
this is interesting he's like I'm
talking to a few people and then like
the next week I went out he had me over
for another interview went out to their
warehouse we had a couple more
conversations and he essentially
verbally offered me the job he's like
great because here's the deal Derek at
the time was the only developer that had
ever worked on any of the code there he
was looking for his first programming
hire that would basically start to
replace pretty important take over for
some stuff yeah and to fix the you know
invariably you know Hodge fge code base
exactly and for this operation that was
running really successful he's like I
have to focus on other areas of the
business now I can't be just head down
as in COD code all day so he verbally
offers me the job he's like and it's I
think this is maybe late November early
December of that year he's like let's
he's like I'm not ready to like start
you before the end of the year let's
let's let's connect in January I'm going
on vacation after January we we'll we'll
reconnect and talk about next steps and
I'm like great I'm going to go work at
my my dream job you know a 23 24 year
old kid um then this happens uh comes
back from beginning of January he's like
hey can we have a quick chat make sure
he's like so change the plans I'm like
what he's like so I got stuck in a
blizzard um during the holiday break and
I had this book called programming Ruby
U it's a famous book in the programming
world it's like it's a pi it's called
the pickaxe because there's a pick like
yeah the pi book and he's like I and
there's this thing called Ruby on Rails
I want to do it all in this I want to
rewrite everything in this like I'm so
excited about this I love rub like I'm
so excited about Ruby I want to redo it
he's like but you don't know Ruby yet
I'm just learning it I found a guy that
lives in San Diego that knows it's
already on the court team this guy named
Jeremy I'm moving to
Portland to help me rewrite everything
and so he said if you can pick this up
I'll hire you then so
so dream shattered take a moment being
like okay that's it is what it is it's
not the end of the world it's just like
okay I get it I had also heard of Ruben
ra about a month before i' watched the
video there famous like video about like
creating a Blog in like 15 minutes or
something I was like oh that SS
interesting so I was like all right I'm
going to start playing with it and start
like kind of getting into it I'm like
kind of excited about it I'm like well
and there's a carrot if I could pick
this up and get good at it and
understand enough like I'll go work with
you know Derek and this guy named Jeremy
you know in in northeast Portland at
this warehouse and work in Ruby I'm like
that great there's a job I I think
there's a job here I could pick this up
you know so I start diving in more Ruban
rails and there's not a lot of
documentation because it's new and I
have to like figure out how to look
under the hood and make make sense of
things and so I started like
well so that I can remember this I
started a Blog I called it Robbie on
Rails um and I started blogging very
very regularly
um and like modifying my own blog tool
and I'm working on you like start
teaching like showing like how I'm doing
things I'm like I had started working on
this one project um called my band spot
which was like going to be a CMS for
bands to manage their own websites
because it was something that I had
built in PHP for a couple of bands in
Portland and I was like oh I'll rewrite
this in Ruby and Ruby on Rails and then
I can show Derek look I'm I'm I'm
learning all this
stuff anyhow that kind
of Ruan rails that it's like hard to
compare it to anything else they seen
maybe and like AI has been its own
interesting thing in the last years but
I feel like with new technologies that
come in and just like change the
trajectory of like the community like so
quickly Ruby on rounds at that time was
just like it w it's it's hard to really
explain but it
was it it it just made our life so much
better as a software as software
developers
that it basic B became this thing
because I was blogging about it these
startups started contacting me and being
like hey will you work on our project
for us can you help me build this thing
because you apparently know about it
because you're talking about it you know
on your blog and so my Dynamic of me
scouring Craigslist looking for PHP jobs
and competing for like you know I'm
trying to ask for like $50 $60 an hour
and other people like well I pay this
one person 15 can you can you meet me at
25 and I'm like yeah how much do I need
to work this week um
to all of a sudden people asking me hey
can you will you work on our project
with us I have this new startup idea and
so that stuff started picking up more
work like that people people were coming
to me and I also part of it was like
another thing because it wasn't just
that I was just blogging Planet argon
also because I was I always wanted to
work with new versions of technology and
and be able to host that easily I felt
like a lot of cheap affordable
hosting was always going to be like way
behind on what version of PHP you could
use so I remember when PHP 5 came out I
offered shared hosting for PHP
5 people people that wanted so if you're
a developer you could do that or you
wanted to use the brand the latest
version of postresql here's an
environment that you could do that with
and so you know a month and a half into
me really diving into Ruby on Rails I
started offering Ruby on Rails hosting
to people and so I started getting
interesting so it's just a server that
was configured to already have a lot of
that stuff running so you could like
multi-tenant or whatever exactly
Multiplex uh a lot of clients on the
same machine yeah this was before we had
like virtualization being like super
common and things like Zen uh xn at the
you know came a couple years later
basically I just knew how to set up like
there was some open source stuff for
managing shared hosting with PHP stuff
and I figured how to change it so that
it could also like spin up a ruby
environment for people so people could
back then you would just include all of
your you know your your gems as part of
your repository like your subversion
Repository or a c CVS or whatever you're
using and so or you would SFTP your
files into your this home directory that
you had and like I just would everybody
would have their own database running
and and stuff like that so I just
learned how to like I could fit like
maybe know 80 to 100 customers per
server um and because none of the
projects were that big in terms of
traffic like they could all kind of
coexist and and it worked out okay um
and then eventually if you wanted to
spend more we would make you know we put
you on servers ahe had less customers on
it that you were sharing space with and
that's that's how that model worked back
then but that so I had those two things
happening I was blogging and I was with
the hosting stuff and then companies
started contacting me to be like hey
will you work on this project people
also asking me hey would you interview
for a company you know you mentioned
like getting approached by you know
opportunity so you know maybe fast
forward four five six months um Derek
from CD bab is like hey you want to chat
again I'm like my my my my my situation
had changed you know quite quite a bit I
was like oh I'm actually I just got a
book deal with O'Reilly um and be weird
for him like you go from like some long
shot like maybe this kid will actually
learn it and to having like an
authoritative book uh or blog and and a
you know potential book deal with
O'Reilly which you know at the time was
basically the king makers yeah of the
tech press essentially like if anybody
was an expert like like having an Ry
book meant you were like the definitive
expert qualified to write on the topic
what was what was going to be your
animal you know on what's your animal
cover uh did they let you choose by the
way no um and and that's a whole another
story but book never got finished
because the company grew too quick and
so that point I turned around the job I
said Derek I'm like I'm going to see
where this goes um and people were
approaching me and maybe there was still
kind OFA I didn't really have employees
outside of it was me and and my kind of
like my
co-founder who uh who was starting to
get more involved in some of the
projects that we're working because
there was a lot more design involved it'
like start a project so we were she
would design stuff and I would build
stuff and so we were doing that and
we're just being I was being very active
in the community there was no Ruby there
was no rails conferences or anything
that that that was like a year later
before those started and so it wasn't
like speaking engagements outside of
like the local so where was the
community I mean it was people reading
your blog were people like on IRC yes
IRC yep was meeting lot of people
through IRC because so people you know
Planet argon had we had a IRC channel
for for people that were hanging out
because they were customers and they
would all like help each other we had
our forums we had there was the Ruby on
Rails Channel um and then there became
this kind of like little back channel in
the rubyan rails Community um called The
Caboose because it's kind of like the
back of the train and we were kind of
like the this became this like little
hodge podge group of people that were
were kind of early adopters through rean
rails and kind of people that were maybe
more
[Music]
businessyoutube
exactly you know he's just you know he's
working on you know selling snowboards
on on you know on the internet and stuff
like that and um so we were all like
helping each other in this back Channel
like kind of like basically it was just
because it was just like a subset
because the r on Rails channel would be
like hundreds of people and this one
made maybe be like 30 to 40 people
there's a photo of us somewhere on
Flickr like at the first rails comp in
Chicago where everybody that was around
for that photo like that was like a big
group of the people and that was like
the first time a lot of us got to meet
each other in person um so it was just
like that Community was definitely IRC
based and blog based um we were all kind
of like referencing each other's blogs
we used that was back when we would have
like a little list of other blogs you
recommended people reading you know like
I for what what we call that but kind of
like a web ring typees thing and um and
there was someone that um kind of you
know looking back at that early that
first one or two years of Ruban rails
like someone was there was like a Ruban
rails blog site it was kind of like an
aggregator that kind of brought all
these like blogs you bringing all the
RSS feeds into one that was pretty
popular it might have been like Planet
Ruby and rails or something and at like
after like a year there was some
Milestone and and then they announced
like who was the most prolific blogger
in the ruband RS community and like I
was like twice as many blog posts as
anyone else that year wow and because I
was just sharing what I learned as I did
it and
um and that so a lot of people knew me
as Robbie on ra stuff like that so that
opened up a lot of doors and then later
in that year so this is like fall 2005
this is when we grow couple large
projects get come my way one of them is
by a design company that had a project
they were doing a winter Olympics
project for this small shoe company
that's based in um Oregon called Nike
and they were their headquarters here
and they were working on a couple
projects for nanki one was the Winter
Olympics and then there was also going
to be a World Cup website and they
wanted to build this backend system and
they were like excited about using Ruban
rails we were like the only people I was
like one of the only
people on the west coast that was like
actively doing much Ruby on rail stuff
at the time and I knew these people in
their local Ruby user meet meetings that
I would go to and I was like hey this
project is too big for
me can't do you want to come help me do
this because most nobody was getting
paid to work with not not very many
people were getting paid in Portland to
work on Ruby on Rails like they were
curious about it or even to work on you
know just program with Ruby in general
but they like to dabble with it it was
like they like their hobby thing you
know they were getting paid to do like I
remember so I ended up kind of
recruiting maybe seven or eight people
and they were working or like an office
attic bought some like folding tables
and some chairs from used furniture
equip like office furniture um store and
all of a sudden it was like eight eight
people working in the Attic on these
projects and I was like I don't know
what happening but I'm like let's just
see where this goes in worst case um
this doesn't work out for more more than
a few months then I just go back to
working for myself or I'll just go talk
to these companies that keep wanting to
maybe hire me so that's when we became
an agency was it was it was very quick
it was a big project so so you had eight
devs yeah like basically like and then
did you feel pressure to go out and
pound the ground and get business to be
able to support those devs well at the
time I was turning away
work wow so you you could literally put
all eight of those devs productively to
were were yeah they were they were going
to be busy for the next few months
because there was a couple projects I
mentioned those Nike ones there was this
other startup um and I remember I our
estimate for that yeah I mean Nike like
maybe the biggest Portland company yeah
um to get them as a client early on
that's that's definitely a feather in
your cap well we were subcontracted
through a designer to be clear Nike I do
not think they would have hired us
directly um we were probably way too
small they did later we did work with
Nike for many many actually still kind
of work with them now but um we're
almost wind it down with them but we we
Nike was one of our was been one of our
largest clients over the years so um
eventually we were mature enough of a
company for them to take seriously but
the um but yeah during that period it
was like we had enough work for people
so they were basically hir them all as
contractors um in like maybe October
November that year and then and then
towards the end of the year we're like
all right well let's let's take a real
look at like it was a so proprietorship
at that point so the business model like
the entity so so you had liability yeah
so January 1st 2006 we became an LLC and
then I offered all those people jobs
employment jobs and most of them took a
job that meant that they were going to
get to work with Ruban rails and that's
what they were in Ruby and that was
exciting and there was basically just
the people that I knew locally that were
excited about it I didn't it wasn't I
don't
remember any any other way of thinking
about how to weigh them up if they were
going to be good people to work with if
they were uh good employees so the
interview process was like kind of
non-existent because you just already
knew them yeah I just met you know I met
them a couple times at like the the
local Ruby Meetup maybe we we you maybe
we got a you know coffee or had lunches
together um maybe grab a drink or
something and I was like I'm just going
to throw these this rag tag group of
kids at the I want say kids but we're
all like in our you know probably mid
20s at the time I was like let's just I
just let's just see what happens and
worst thing as I go back to doing we all
go back to what we were doing right yeah
and the thing that I
knew I felt like I had some at least a
skill set was because I had already had
a couple you know years of doing the
Consulting work that I knew how to at
least like do a little bit of
negotiating I knew how to do think about
the sales process and knew that I needed
to spend time on marketing and promoting
the company and reconnecting with
customers after you wrap up a small
project like a few months later to see
what else is going on so you can get
recurring work with you know like I that
was so so maintaining that relationship
and and having it not be a oneoff but uh
you know a an iterated game so to speak
exactly and the and meanwhile I felt
like a lot of the software Engineers
that had been experienced with they just
wanted to work on the code and they were
really excited about the tech itself and
I think back to what you were you know
we were talking about earlier in the
conversation where I was interested in
what it could do for a company so I was
like I felt like I was in a much more
natural I mean I was super excited about
playing with Ruan rails and everything
but I was like what can I do with this
what kind of web apps can I make for
people what kind of business problems
can I solve look how much quicker we can
build this thing for these people and it
was also an overlap at the time with
like a lot of like web design and ux
improve improvements in maturity I think
in the industry where there was like a
lot of patterns you can pull from web
standards browser you know things that
were happening it's just like a web
standards being as that was like its own
thing the fact that we were even geeking
out about like HTML and CSS consistency
as a industry was like that overlapped
at like at just the right time that it
just made I think Ruby on Rails came in
and so all new web apps could use these
new patterns and so they looked and felt
better and for users and so like I feel
like it kind of just all got bundled up
into that thing like oh rubben Ra's
applications feel better because you're
using all these new standards and so
there was kind of this weird thing where
like because you're using these new
standards you care about the end users
and that's going to make better for your
business and and look how much nicer
things are yeah versus these clunky web
apps that everybody would be throwing
together because it' be a bunch of
software web
developers designing the interfaces
quite often and they were just like they
weren't great they were just making it
you know doing their best and they
weren't really thinking about the design
side yeah and I think bootstrap came out
like shortly afterward and was pretty
widely adopted by the r on Rails
Community as well and that that kind of
standardized and removed a lot of the
decisions that you had to make as a
developer um yeah and that's like really
the strength of rails in my humble
opinion is the convention over
configuration um just like this works
well enough let's not split hairs and so
while a lot of people might have been
like um you know saying oh rails is not
high performance or enough or I needed
to do specifically this
thing you were just getting down to work
building stuff for clients exactly it
was just I I you know it was a little
bit of a David Goliath battle too back
then it was kind of like look this is
kind of Underdog thing we're like coming
through and we're like no we can build
really sophisticated applications with
this technology that people were
like skeptical to say the least like
this isn't mature it's funny because now
you know 20 years later or whatever uh
it's I feel like we're having similar
conversations like oh ruon RS is like
this old thing nobody wants to use it
anymore it's too mature too mature and
like we go back to when I used to have I
used to have to have conversations with
large companies that like someone at
their company had heard of rubben like I
really want I'm they were like really
proponed like we want to build this web
app for this internal thing but I need
you to help me convince the CTO that
this is a safe decision this is not
going to like ruin us somehow or going
to plague us with security things or
just we're going have to throw so much
Hardware to keep this thing running I
mean were you doing a lot of like full
codebase rewrites like Dereck sers was
asking or were you just building new
functionality out with rails a lot of it
at the time early on was new
functionality new web apps um and the I
think it probably took about a year and
a half two years before we started
getting calls from companies to help
them come in and repair their existing
Ruban rounds applications but there
there was a couple projects that were
were rewrites or kind of modernizing
their existing platform a bit so like
maybe there's a part of some web app
that they were using like hey we want to
put we want to build a new interface for
like there was a company that worked in
travel and they wanted to build a new
interface for travel agents um that
could interface with the same database
so one of the things that I was kind of
you know air quoting known for in the
community was being a big post rescue y
person but also being understanding that
there's a lot of Legacy I came from a
world where remember I mentioned earlier
my previous job I was working at a
company where we specialized in post and
I I had a the database to me was like
always like this thing that never assume
that you're not going to have you're
only going to have one application that
interfaces with that you may have
multiple things that are interacting
with it so I always felt like a lot of
business rules should be in the database
which was like a hard Paradigm for me to
wrap my head around when I got kind of
adopted Ruby on Rails for yeah because
you're doing like migrations in code
essentially as opposed to structuring
your database in a specific way and then
adapting your apps around that existing
kind of schema right yeah well
technically uh database migrations
didn't exist in rubs when I started
using RS uh you saw you all of our first
scheme is you had to do all your write
out your SQL create table statements
alra table statements that came in maybe
a year two years into rubian rails after
I started using it and I think probably
help I don't remember if they adopted
that from somewhere else but it was
definitely like a big game changer but
it was more of the you already have a
legacy database that has some different
application how can we make a ruon rails
application work with that same data set
and make maybe new reporting tools or
some new interfaces on it so I was
writing a lot of I wrote a lot of
articles in some Library ruby gems that
were for like working with Legacy
databases so you can put active record
and have it connect to some um like
Microsoft SQL Server thing or an Oracle
database or some old MySQL plus database
where the DAT the naming conventions are
wildly not what we would consider normal
in the Ruban rails Community just like a
different way of doing it so so but then
you can make it feel more rails likee
and so get the benefits of building web
apps quickly with rbrand rounds but
still getting to leaning on an existing
database and having to work around
database triggers or store procedures
and how do you make that work within the
rub rub Ruban rails world and so that
was like a part of my I guess my Niche
was because I had that skill set and I
was like how do I work around and still
get to use and leverage ruon rails um so
we would get pulled in to help out with
companies that were trying
to have like a hybrid system there's a
lot of companies sneaking rails in on
this very small thing and and like their
dream would be like and then eventually
we'll show that this works like a trojan
horse
eventually the whole comp going to Mo
rails but we have to prove out the
concept with this exactly so that there
was a lot of like that type of work that
came kind of came our way as well and
then over the years we ended up
realizing that a lot of our typical
clients that were startups they would
not be our clients you know two years
down the road because they didn't figure
out how to make their startup work right
and so most startups do not uh get
product Market fit they don't get
traction and they are not able able to
raise subsequent rounds um yeah yeah but
but obviously Planet argon from a
sustainability standpoint is is going
strong I mean you're like almost 22
years in at this point uh how big is
your team now we are I think
approximately 14 15 people at the moment
um it's funny like every time I get
asked that question I don't exactly know
I have to look at the slack Channel um
it's always like kind of weaving in we
do bring on contractors here and there
as well we've usually got a couple
interns um so that numbers in terms of
working directly with with clients and
like I guess selling the clients is that
something you do a lot of yourself still
yeah I do a lot of the business
development at the company so I'm
usually one of the first for people that
companies will talk to and kind of like
help make sure it's a good fit for the
company we're not like a large enough
company to really have in it's
interesting people always talk we invest
in like we have a marketing person that
helps out with our marketing but when it
comes to Sal sales uh there's this
interesting thing because the type of
work that we focus on now is more on
helping organizations that have already
invested a lot into their rubyan rails
infrastructure and platform how to help
them modernize that how to help them
like do some refactoring projects or we
are their primary development team
because there's a lot of web web apps
out there where a company might have had
a small development team internally
build or maybe they worked with a small
agency or a couple of Freelancers to
build some internal tool but it wasn't
like a it was never intended to be a
thing that they were going to have
consistent full-time software Engineers
working on they don't and they're not
really set up like they're you know it's
you know they're a travel company and
they're like what we don't know what to
we don't know how we would keep like two
three software developers busy fulltime
right so they have these apps that need
support and but they need more
reliability than say just working with a
freelancer and so we're kind of like in
this space of like you maybe for aside
from the companies that have their own
engineering teams that use us to help
them with make some upgrades and
modernization type projects or
refactoring uh we're kind of in this
interesting middle sphere of like where
when you outgrow like your Freelancers
but you're not really thinking you want
to grow into having your own full-time
team we end up being so so a lot of our
companies were on regular retainer with
them where they are basically reserving
time with us every month for us to keep
an eye on their application to respond
to bug fixes error alerts performance
issues
and they always have a backlog of
feature improvements and updates that
they're looking to make and so we're
we're their team you know and so we so
our our developers are working across
multiple clients like in a given week so
it's a little bit Contex switching but
they're all it's all ruby and rounds for
the most part and so we're just like so
our business model kind of went from
working with startups and helping them
estimate out their you know their
product Market fit and hoping that they
figure out how to sell this thing and so
that they can get more budget in the
future to keep investing to now we're
like hey you already invested in this
thing you know you need to continue
investing in the upkeep of it and keep
things updated and um and we're not
afraid to roll our hands you know or or
roll our sleeves up and get dirty on
older applications because a lot of
projects come to us and they have not
been tended to um in years because
they're like well we had a couple people
work on it and then that person left and
then someone came in and they never
upgraded it and now 5 years has passed
but we you but 30 people at our company
use this application every day we need
to know that someone can take care of it
so since we've been around forever we've
seen all flavors of that over the years
and so we can come in be like yeah we
can stabilize this and work on a plan to
help you upgrade this and interesting so
so a big selling point of uh getting
Planet argon to work on your uh your
code base it sounds like first of all
you've been around you're not going
anywhere so there's that peace of mind
associated with like Hey we're going to
get these people up to speed on how our
code works and they're going to be able
to continue to maintain it uh for a
longer period of time and it's not like
a freelancer where they're going to um
move or um just change careers or
something like that like that a lot of
that risk is mitigated and at the same
time it is a lot less expensive than
having your
own you know developer staff just
maintaining that project and and in in
many cases sounds like a lot of these uh
particular projects are not such that
they would warrant having
uh a bigger team no and and I think I
think some companies fall into a trap
where I've speak with some developers
like yeah I'm like the solo
developer on this project for this
company and I've been working here for a
decade and maybe five years ago they had
a cooworker another developer they have
they have co-workers but there's like
but like a peer you know what I mean and
like I can't kind of see where you're go
is this is the tacit knowledge Time Bomb
basically like they walk out the door
and like suddenly nobody knows how
anything works exactly
this this story is like one of the most
consistent thing this is where this is
another one of the so it's interesting
I'm actually helping a company right now
and
so I'm kind of like in a weird way I get
one of our service offering is kind of
like it's you know Under the Umbrella we
do Consulting right as well and but a
little bit of was
like um like business I want to say
family therapy for teams of like you
know I will you know it's it's it's
almost guaranteed that always like once
every 6 months I'm going to get a com
we're going to get a call from some
someone that works at a company that
maybe has 20 to 50 employees and they
have one software engineer that's been
there for a really long time and they're
like hey we have a situation we've
either there's enough work that we tried
to bring in additional people and people
leave and they cannot work with this
person that's been around forever and
this is right they come in and they're
like great I'm going to come in and be
some you know New Blood on the project
and a year year and a half later they
quit and they're like I can't work with
that person um but then they're like but
that this person has been so dependable
for us over the years and we're really
nervous about losing this person but but
maybe it's time for them to go you know
and they're in this weird situation
like can you come and help us assess
this like can interesting so almost kind
of like U you're you're doing like a uh
like a case like a a briefing you're
you're going in as the investigator to
like try to understand the situation and
recommend courses of action
yeah or just like can they help them
understand can we survive if this person
were to leave you know there's always
like people talk about like oh what what
happens if someone gets hit by a bus you
know why we document things and this is
why documentation is important and or
why we re reate automated tests so that
we know that if someone new comes in
they know that they're not breaking
everything well that sounds great but
also when you're a really small team the
reality is if no one's reading your
documentation and you you're able to
keep a lot in your head you start you
start making concessions on what things
like things that might help a healthy
development team work and flourish you
like well you deprioritize some stuff
and you continue to do that and then
people come in and they're like Hey
where's the documentation like
well you know I've changed this thing
six times and no one's ever looked at it
so I just I haven't maintained it in
Forever you know like the read me file
hasn't changed in five years and you're
just like okay I get it I can be
empathetic to that I understand how that
happens when you're working in an
environment where you're putting out
fires you're being reactive to like hey
you're keeping everything running and
you're like kind of like thinking about
someone spinning a bunch of plates at
the same time you know and it could be a
lot of work for one person to oversee
the whole system but if there's no one
to collaborate with consistently whether
it's because of you're doing because
you're just not great to work with or
because you don't trust that other
people are worthy of being part of your
team whatever this situation is um or
there's just not enough budget to
warrant mult multiple people to be to
work with you uh which ends up being
quite a common thing you know this this
kind of problem will resurface and so
then the companies like what have we
invested in or we screwed if this person
walks out the door but also maybe they
need to leave they need to leave and so
for whatever reason I think I can come
into those situations and and be fairly
neutral I understand how the developer
gets there I understand how the comp or
the business owner might be really
concerned about this and I can like I
can talk with these people and kind of
Na you're kind of like the Rockstar
Whisperer almost a little bit but you
know I'm trying to not use the Rockstar
thing too much uh they usually just come
in in like trash hotels and leave and um
but it is it's it's an interesting like
come in and maybe I have
enough I'm well known enough in some
circles that people give me a benefit of
the doubt that I'm not coming in and
just like telling someone what they want
to hear so I mean do do people see you
and like panic because like oh no no
they they brought him and that must mean
I'm like on my way out or no or like are
you often able to like repair the
situation or or just by introducing a
collaboratory like discourse are you
able to fix a lot of the uh kind of like
documentation not getting updated tests
not getting written things like
that it's a great question the I've had
some successes I've had I'd say the
companies have had some failures with
trying to correct the situation and
where where it works out for everybody
it doesn't always end up working out for
everybody in some of those situ and I
don't I do not believe I have a
reputation coming in and like help
helping people lose their jobs um I
think I'm much more on this side of
probably much more on the side of like
helping people keep their jobs and maybe
making some incremental changes but the
people have you know it's like a it's in
some ways it's like getting pulled in
for like a you know like a
physical therapist you go in and like
try to get some work done and they show
you all things you're like oh great I do
these stretches every day this will be
good for me and this will this pain will
go away you know and I know that if you
don't do the work consistently then
you're just going to end up at the you
know the physical therapist in five
years and they're going to like you're
like oh yeah I remember I did this
before so there is a lot of like people
need to want to change some of how their
approach their work and stuff like that
and so that's that's the thing I'm you
know I've been you know coincidentally
in the last couple years things that
I've been doing is first professional
development is taking a lot more
curriculum related to improving my
coaching skills like okay I'm I'm a
coaching these situations how do I
better talk with these people get them
to think about their and help them solve
their own problems rather than me being
super prescriptive and like I think you
should do it because this is what planet
argon does and if you just do this it'll
be great for you everybody kind of needs
to figure out come to some of those aha
moments themselves right um and which I
think was also an important thing to
learn early on as a consultant
especially for designers that if you I
always felt we always when we've had
designers on our team if they work on
working with a client on a design I
honestly believe that I've seen way more
success if the if the through that
collaborative process of a designer
working on things that if the designer
can help the client feel
like show them how their ideas is what
manifested the current version of the
design versus like a designer going away
and coming up back with some magical
representation of what they thought they
heard the designers that always felt
like made it
appear that it was actually so much of
the client's idea and they just
materialized it like that's to me like
an effective consultant effective coach
is like helping someone see come to this
kind of like realization and kind of
coaching them that way and and also
being aware enough to like that you
might not know the best answer and you
got to find something that's going to
work well for them I'm not saying you're
manipulating them but I think it's more
of a there's a there's a strategy there
I think that can be yield better results
collectively so the um so when in these
scenarios around coming in and helping
helping out things it's a lot of like a
strategy that we'll kind of take on um
is doing this right now for one company
where you know I'm participating sitting
in a lot of their meetings and taking
notes asking questions asking the dumb
questions I always like let me ask a
dumb question I said that if you say
that like a bunch people disarms people
pretty quickly I think um because then
you can ask the questions you really
want to ask but um and not have to rely
on assumptions but like start thinking
about like if you if we come in like
show them that we're going to use the
documentation like hey we want to like
one exercise will be we want one of our
developers to get your app up and
running in their local environment um
and like maybe a goal would be how hard
is it to bring in someone else to come
into your
team get acclimated to your system your
repo or multiple repos and be able to
deploy a small bug fix maybe even just
change the footer copyright date or
something on your on your web app how
painful is it for a company for for
someone to come in and do that that
because I feel like changing the date in
the
footer if that takes several days to be
able to get to that point like is that
unless you're bringing on regular people
maybe that maybe not be the biggest
concern but if you're a company that's
concerned about like hey feels like
everything's slowing down I feel like
those are like sometimes symptom of that
and like you can look at those types of
how hard is it to do some really small
tasks and people can come in and so I
think if you can start removing like
addressing those things you start to
highlight a bunch of of other pain
points that makes it difficult for
people to come in because a lot of those
companies that are calling us they're
not just calling us because they're like
hey help us better understand the
situation they are truly calling us
because they're like hey things have you
know like our product backlog seems Log
Jam things like our delivery time is
taking forever I I'm starting to lose
confidence in my team's ability to
estimate when we can release something
so that means I can't promise our
customers that this new feature is going
to be out by X because I just don't
believe it anymore because it's like
we're almost there we're almost there
and then like months pass and they're
like can you come in and like can we
hire your team to come in and help us
build these things but they're like they
also know they like I don't think it's
going to be that easy they know like you
can't just throw more people at the
problem it's like how do what's going on
here what can we do to smooth the
process and onboard new people so that
other people can contribute to this
project and I think if you have a piece
of software regardless of the framework
you're using if if it's difficult for
other people to come in and work on it I
honestly think that that's not a a good
good sign that you have a great software
developer I feel like that means you
have a developer that's keeps everything
in their head and that's that's not it's
not it's not the end of the world
especially if they're like in personally
invested in their company but if they're
an employee and you don't really feel
like you can trust someone else to come
in and take over for them yeah that's
that's a concern to me and I always I
remember thinking I remember we had a
project manager once who was so
organized with how they Pro like their
process it was so consistent and how
they documented everything they did I
was like you're making it so easy for
someone else to come in and just take
over your job and they're like and
that's why you keep me and I was like
aha that's great that's a great it's
it's very much counter to the intuition
that a lot of developers have like by
not documenting things like I've got all
this proprietary knowledge in my head
and uh it's my uh I guess my retirement
plan is is like carrying around a whole
bunch of details about the code base and
uh and not you know writing those down
anywhere that's my job security so so
you you found it to be the opposite like
companies will actually acknowledge like
oh because this person is so transparent
with everything that's a that's a
strength it it should be seen as a
strength it should be seen as a strength
but is it seen as a strength by a lot of
managers or do a lot of managers be like
oh well we can replace this this person
really easily with like a you know a
cheaper developer just out of college
because they've documented exactly what
they need to do does that kind of
transparency hurt your longevity at an
organization to some
extent that's a that's an interesting
one I you know I was speaking with
someone
recently uh because one of the things we
also offer now is recruiting uh as
helping companies hire people because I
know a lot of people in the industry
that may have jobs that they like but
would be open to talking to someone and
so I'm like I am pretty well connected I
can try to connect the dots and maybe I
can make a little bit money on that
introduction but aside from that um I
talk with some people and they're like I
got asked what's your opinion on uh how
long like a 10 year how long of a 10e
developer should have at a company and
they had and this was from a like a
pretty seasoned software
engineer um that's been at a company for
maybe like five years as a engineering
manager he's like a he manages a team
and he he's heard from other people in
the company so he's in Engineering
Management but he's heard from other
parts of the business leadership that
there's a curiosity about how long
should we keep developers because if
we're not cycling in new people and
getting new fresh ideas one we might be
getting stagnant but two um May maybe
there's a competitive thing with
salaries you know maybe we can hire
people further away or whatever and
there's other things there but like so
he's like he's like he's like have you
heard a lot about that so admittedly I
don't feel like I've had a lot of
conversations like about that that that
was a recent conversation I had and I
was like oh that's interesting because
I've always think it's be great to have
say for a long time but sometimes I do
think from like a growth perspective if
you depending what people's if you as a
software let's just assume most people
listen to this or software Engineers is
your goal to be at a company for a
really long time or is your can build
like a longevity and like have uh make a
mark for a specific organization that I
mean I come from a maybe you know a
couple you know a slightly different
area where like the idea of working at a
company for a long time actually sounded
good to me when I was young I'm like oh
I don't want to have to switch jobs all
the time and like like hopefully I'm not
like losing my job or getting laid off
on a regular you know every five years
like that I think that maybe in some
ways me thinking I'm going to do my own
thing was a way to avoid that because he
would see that play out and still my dad
worked at his last job for like 25 years
you know yeah what about your
grandpa he check he that's a good
question I don't I don't know how I
think he actually did a lot more job
hopping because it was early on when
like he was like he at least he moved a
lot like the family moved for work a lot
and so I don't know if that was like
maybe the manager he worked more in like
management maybe that was the manage
track in the you know the 60s of moving
like they go to their Minnesota then
they moved to Illinois and then they
moved to California yeah I mean I
definitely have heard from older folks
uh you know my grandpa stayed at the
same company basically his entire career
as an engineer um you know my dad has
run his own practice with like similar
partners for right most of his career uh
it's it's
pretty um common for like people from
that they were born in like the the 40s
50s 60s to just stay at a place assuming
that they can get a good job and like
this definitely holds true in Asia for
example in Japan like they have the
whole company man notion like you get a
job at a company and and ideally you
stay and there's like the social
contract where they teach you new skills
and you keep getting promoted and
additional
responsibility how do you feel about
that like do you think that that is a
good fit for most developers that you
know or do you think most developers do
want to be changing a lot
uh I I wonder if it's
a I don't you know it's such an
interesting thing I think you know for
me you know I've been doing working at
plan Aram for such a long time now you
know like it's funny plus years and I'm
like there's a part of me like is this
where I retire I don't know the answer
to that I don't know like do I still
have a business in five years is always
running a Consul consultancy is a
complex mess of like es and flows and
hiring people having to lay people off
if there's down ears and stuff like that
it's it's just a cycle and then but but
at least I get to kind of control the
narrative to some degree at least I feel
like I'm slightly in control at times
most of the time not but you know I
think about when people are work for the
general software engineering like if
you're
I'm just wondering if there's a certain
element of like do
you I I wonder how it's going to impact
us when we're for for people that are in
the industry and are and are employees
somewhere and aren't maybe not in
control of
it I honestly think that the thing we
don't talk about is age as very often as
being probably one of the most common
biases of you know things that we're
discriminating whether we we want to
talk we openly mention it or not but I
do think I we talk about diversity in
Tech but you know rarely do I see a a
lot of startups where you'll see some
older people in the company you know
working there people that are in their
60s you know getting hired and and I've
been in part of those conversation like
ah that person's like it's hard to teach
an old dog new tricks and stuff like
that they're not going to like so
there's a interesting challenge there I
think if people maybe I think some
sometimes people will find that
themselves having they're kind of stuck
in a job or feel like this is this a Ive
space now at their their last 10 years
of their career because they're maybe
nervous about rejection trying to put
themselves out there and I don't know
how this is going to play out over the
next several years you know le as I as
as I get to continue to get older um you
know there's kind of these weird phases
we get through and like sometimes people
think that like I'm not up to date on
the newest things and like what are
these kids in their 20s doing nowadays
and but where's that kind of where's
that where does that go at some point
when people are feeling like they can't
get a job somewhere else and so might
they stick around just for fear of
rejection or or because they've been
rejected and like well at least I have a
stable thing so I'm just going to sink
in here and maybe my opportunities are
not going to be drastically there's not
going to be a lot of other growth
opportunities whether that be salary or
promotions but like I can at least stick
in this is kind of my area that I can
control and there's I'll stick here
until I retire um a lot of startups
probably aren't they'll talk about
retirement plans but do they think long
term about like what's a 20 30 year 30
year career look like for someone at
their company they're still trying to
figure out how to make the next few
years work let alone think about that
far they can talk about we've got great
benefits but you know I mean like
startups are going to get acquired
there's going to be all kinds of
creative destruction the notion that you
could get a job at a startup and still
be working there 30 years from now I
think is probably not realistic for not
you know in a majority of cases but a
lot of that is because developers tend
to work at a startups especially over
here on you know the West Coast where
you got you know you got Seattle with
all the startups you got San Francisco
and uh you've got uh you know the Bay
Area with all the startups I I do think
that like if you go to like a more
traditional kind of
like industry like banking or hotels or
you know um hospitals or any like i'
I've heard the statistic that like
two-thirds of developers work outside of
proper Tech
and I think in those roles you know it
may not be so unrealistic to just work
at the same company Long
Term but from your experience working
like What proportion of the companies
you work with are tech companies to
Planet
orgon how would you define what a tech
company is Quincy yeah so I would say a
tech company it would be like the
product is some sort of like app or
software tool like at last is a tech
company they have you know this Suite of
software tools you know Salesforce is a
tech company is you know Ford a tech
company I would argue they aren't
because they're a car company they may
position themselves as a tech company
but like that's just a very small aspect
of what they really do which is Source
parts from around the world and design
cars and you know make sure that they
meet all these different regulations and
stuff right so the tech part as much as
they may emphasize that is actually
probably a pretty small proportion of
the number of people on their team that
are doing just that I mean you could
argue like Finance is Tech but it's not
really Tech in the sense that probably a
very small minority of the people who
work in finance are software Engineers
same thing with like media and other
Industries like that so I I I would say
very specifically like tech companies
like Microsoft is a tech company you
know so so I I think I would reach for
that Common Sense kind of definition of
tech and not um not like a marketer type
definition of what constitutes working
in Tech no that that I think that's
actually a really good way to kind of
frame it I I think the thing that I I
struggle you know I've talked about this
in the past on some other podcasts and
stuff like that I've always struggled a
little bit with tech because I felt like
it was too encompassing I think we kind
of overuse it like oh we all work in
Tech because we're all software
Engineers I'm like well you know you you
work in finance right or you're work in
healthcare you got to think about
Healthcare regulations like you know
yes there's some software within that
healthcare related company but it's is
that it's it's just an interesting I
guess you're using Tech to solve some
problems I suppose but I feel like I was
like is is the is your skill set as a
software
engineer just that you're really good at
knowing how to code um solve problems
with software code or that you know how
to solve problems in that specific
domain you know and you buil up that
skill set and so like if someone's
working at a Healthcare company and they
want to go work at a Banking Company you
may may not want to put like you can
talk about all the health healthc care
stuff certifications you might have and
all but you're probably like I
understand certifications and compliance
type things that would make it I'll have
to learn this in the finance industry
but I can figure it out but I don't I'm
not going to show up day one knowing all
of that and but so I think you could you
know if anyone listening is like domain
expertise from working in a specific
field as opposed to like nobody has
domain expertise in tech tech is kind of
like the uh implementation detail
through which the product is created I
can I can speak a language uh well
there's some people at the company they
need to speak this one particular
language yes I can do that um may not be
like but can you talk about these other
Concepts and the this stuff in the
domain so I think that's you anyhow so
your question was how many like What
proportion of your uh clients at Planet
orgon are what I would narrowly Define
as tech companies in the sense that
they're creating software products
um it's interesting uh even the
companies that
I'm we've definitely worked with a lot
of tech companies over the years I think
right now it's probably in the range of
like 15 20% of our clients okay okay so
so that that kind of matches with the
global like the actual like us industry
is Tech is just a small part of that
right yeah um so do you think that uh a
developer going to work for like one of
your you don't have to name a specific
client but like what do you think the
chances are that a developer going to
work for one of those clients would
likely be able to work for 20 25 years
and you know get the the gold watch and
get the retirement and all that stuff I
don't know if that stuff really still
exists anymore but but basically be able
to save up enough money that they could
actually retire at some point like and
and that they don't have to be careerly
jumping from job to job just because it
pays like 10% more each time and and
that's the strategy of course many
developers employ conventional wisdom is
if you change jobs every 18 months or so
you're going to maximize your income
over time by by doing that and that if
you stay in your current job you're less
likely to be able to get AR raay because
you wield less bargaining power because
everybody wants to stay their job they
don't want to have to go through the
gauntlet every 18 months of trying to
get a new job right true but like what
proportion of those clients do you think
that like people could realistically
plan to work there
indefinitely you
know I mean you take like take Nike as
an example like that is definitely a
place people can can persist for a long
time
um
the it's interesting because I think
there's a lot of uh companies are that
we're working with where they're a lot
more distributed now and I think that
sense of identity in organization and
the remote world is hard for me to wrap
my head around in some ways like we're a
remote company now we weren't up until
the pandemic and interesting so you let
your lease go we let our lease go you
know we had but when that happened we
had already talked about maybe
downsizing and maybe having s hiring
people a little bit further away not
just focusing on you know because
basically we were 90% of our team would
always be based in Portland and so I was
like who are the best people that we can
afford in Portland Oregon you know who
do we move out here we would move people
um you we move people here maybe two
years before the pandemic we'd moved
them to Portland you know and so and
we'd also have to think who else is
opening up shop in Portland
airbnbs you know setting up an office
and are they potentially now a
competitor for our talent you know um
because they use Ruby on Rails for some
of their stack at the time and so those
are the things you used to think about
in a location based thing so I'm
thinking about like company people
sticking around at a company for 25
years 30 years and in a remote world
I'm just like there's a part of me I
like have some trouble wrapping my head
around what that looks like and the
sense of like longevity and getting that
go you know like and there's there's
been companies that have been able to do
that for you know the last couple
decades I'm just not as familiar with
them I don't have a lot of reference
points I'm just like yeah because
there's another part of me it's just
like it feels
very you know like it seems like
everybody that works to plan enjoys it
they raid us well we got you know
awarded you know one of the best places
workplaces you know it's like this
online thing last year and I'm just like
but but it feels different for me you
know just being completely honest I'm
like this is a really different thing
era for me or I'm trying to get R my
head around how do you bond with your
team and what is what is what is it what
is what is it that you like because we
don't have I'm not able to make you
waffles on January the first first the
first day first business day of the year
that was always a tradition like how do
we we don't what is it about some
waffles in like one of those uh those
boxes with the dry iceers something the
probably would very good waffles so I
think is it's an interesting thing where
I'm
um to answer that question like I have
no clue like and I'm not going to
pretend that pretend to know I'm just
like will people want to work and sign
into someone's whatever in 10 years
whatever the equipment of someone's
slack is and every day and chat with
each other for like at some point you're
going to want to chat with other people
I don't know so yeah I mean who knows
maybe we'll have teleportation or
something like like or it'll just be
like trivially you know easy to get
around the world and we'll we'll figure
it out some sort of system that doesn't
emit tons of carbon every time we get on
a plane who knows uh but uh yeah I I can
definitely see like remote work throwing
a a wrench in like long-term planning
and and like our intuition for team
Rapport we're fully Re remote free C
Camp and we've got about 30 people
around the world working on the open
source code base and working on
instructional design and uh you know
like we we meet for you know one 30 to
45 minute slot each week and the rest of
it is just kind of ad hoc meetings and
stuff and how do you build rapport well
you know we're flying people into Dallas
to to hang out for a while What
proportion of your team is in Portland
though
now let's see there's what four so
there's four of us here now um two of
them we hired after the pandemic started
um so only one
person because my business partner moved
out of moved moved out of the area
during the pandemic so um so yeah we
have one person that was pre pandemic
from Portland that's still with us so
we've just had to get used to a cycle of
constant change so I think that also
speaks to why it's harder for me to wrap
my head around plus long term there and
like now I'm thinking more of like there
are certain types of business entities
we can we have had clients that we've
been working with for you know 8 to 12
Years yet we've been able to show them
that we can have Engineers on our team
come and go and we can manage the
projects keep continuity and persist
like some collective knowledge about how
to keep these projects running and stuff
like that so that's one of our so
there's a now A Thing part of me it's
like longevity is important with employ
I want employees to want to work here as
long as they are but also 10year length
is less of an emphasis now I think
because I'm just like this might be a
really good opportunity for someone for
a few years you get a lot of experience
maybe at some point in their career
we're either really good place for
someone early on in their career as a
junior developer to get exposed to a lot
of stuff that could be really valuable
to them and we're also a good place for
people that are further along in their
career and they're maybe they've seen a
lot and they're like you know what I
want to apply some of the skills to a
broad range of problems and I can bring
in all this knowledge I have across get
to work with lots of different projects
Now versus just working at one company
so that's kind of
our our recruitment strategy in some
ways now is like we can hire both ends
of that and like the people that are
kind of in that middle part of their or
early middle like ambitious part of
their thing we're not we don't we're not
set up to like have lots of promotions
we've got like a couple tiers yeah um
and that and we can't keep raising our
hourly rates at the same rate that your
salary range wants to increase go work
at that startup that's getting funded
and can offer those other things like
what I promise you is you're going to
get we're only going to ask you to work
this much a week we're going to work on
different these types of client projects
it's going to be a little messy you're
going to need to be okay with that but
you're going to get a lot of exposure to
things and we're not going to call you
on the weekends or in the evening to
work on things unless there's like a
really big fire that we need your help
with otherwise we just want consistent
stability and we want to do good client
work and enjoy the rest of our what the
other projects we've got going on in our
lives yeah I mean that's a huge selling
point for an employer to just be able to
say no we really mean it we're really
serious about you know the 40-hour work
week and not having to be like patched
in constantly on slack or whatever right
um so yeah cudos you for uh figuring out
kind of like a proposition where you can
compete with you know companies that
have way more money to throw at
developers
um one of the things that you know
strikes me talking about uh longevity in
careers is you know maintainability in
software and continuity in having that
code base that's been a core focus of
yours and I'd like to shift gears a
little bit and talk about the
maintainable podcast excellent podcast
which I've enjoyed listening to before I
do I just want to point out that earlier
I joke that teleportation might be
possible in like 15 years I just want to
say that I think that's probably the
least likely technology that we'll have
and I don't even think we'll have
teleportation in the 24th century when
Star Trek is happening I I think it's
it's such a hard problem that I doubt it
will actually exist so that was a joke
for all the uh physics people that are
listening in uh the doctors all the
people out there that are like the
philosophers um thinking that I I don't
want them to walk away thinking that I
think teleportation is going to happen
anytime soon so um you've done 160
episodes of maintainable 160 episodes so
you've really you know maintained that
podcast and you've optimized for you
know longevity in that podcast what's
the core focus of the show
consistent conversations I think is part
of it a consistent formula
the the the way I look when I started
the project there was a couple things
you know you know
useful to mention about how I think
about approaching new projects like when
I started that particular the podcast
but how I think about projects in
general now um but I knew that I wanted
to have conversations with people that I
felt like would hopefully still show to
be relevant and valuable in then you
know 10 to 15 years after the
conversation was had and so I wanted to
have conversations with people not not
about what's
new what's exciting what's the newest
trends I mean that stuff occasionally
you know trickles into the conversations
you know like teleportation we don't
talk about I don't talk about the future
and stuff as much and um mainly because
I don't know it is and I'm not g I'm not
a good predictor of these things but
what I do know is I've seen a lot of
consistent problems resurface regardless
of the technology platform I also wanted
to have conversations with people that
are not specifically you know I I'm I'm
a Ruby on Rails software engineer was
Robbie on Rails think that's my
company's core Focus for the most part
we also do some react and some other
stuff I don't personally do much react
maybe written like 20 lines of react
code my whole life um it's not the it's
not the thing that kind of excited me
because again I'm more excited about
what can I do than what I can do you
know what the the technology itself was
and we already had enough client work to
keep me busy working with Ruby and rail
stuff so the so when I did the
maintainable software pack podcast I
want to have conversations about what
were some good different people's
perspectives on what it meant to be a to
maintain your software to what it what
well-maintained software looks like what
it feels like what it's like to work
with it on a regular basis what's what
is it like to join a project where
there's already a lot of existing code
because I think a lot of people in the
education because it's just the way it
ends up working sometimes is that you
you get to learn how to build new things
what when you you get introduced to
programming and again like I we talked
earlier at the very beginning of the
conversation it was like hey if you
write all this code you can play this
game but it'd be like what if we could
modify it how do we make how do we
update it how do we improve upon it how
do we make it easier to develop with how
do we remove developer friction that
stuff is the stuff that I'm most
interested about because I felt like
Ruby on Rails when I was interested like
it removed a lot of friction made a lot
of decisions for me and It produced
better easier to build things but then
it didn't
prevent problems from occurring still
within teams knowledge getting lost
documentation problems
um how we think about testing and how we
have conversations about technical debt
and overdue upgrades and how do we work
with people that don't understand what
tech de Tech debt is or do we even use
the word Tech debt yeah let's just
describe Tech that very quickly like two
sentence explanation of what that is for
anybody listening who doesn't uh
understand that concept yet yeah this is
a question I ask almost every one of my
guests and it's very rarely consistently
the same so if even my definition is
going to be my version of it so I see
Tech Deb
is um the things that are that have
accumul like kind of we use this
metaphor because because it kind of goes
back to like you you get debt and you
pay it off is kind of like you know in
the you know when you're getting a loan
for something and we've kind
of we've taken that and maybe stretched
a little further in our industry some
you know I don't think I like to use the
word technical debt but I like to talk
about it in the sense that it's it's I
think the best example of it and it
should be six two two sentence I'm not
doing a very good job at that uh defin
this is why it's I think it's why I love
asking the question is it's hard uh to
answer clearly because it's I think of
it as like the you've made some
intentional decisions or maybe
even subconsciously decided to forgo
something to get something done now but
you're probably going to later going to
need to later come back and revisit
something but maybe something's good
enough for now or you've said this is
going to get this this code change is
going to get out the door but you know
we probably in you know down the road a
little bit we're going to need to go
back and revisit this thing because this
is not going to scale for whatever
reason and so there's that where's that
balance between is it is it a debt or is
it just like a concession that you made
a tradeoff it's kind of like I think
tradeoffs is maybe is a better way to
frame them sometimes but I think another
way to look at is like you can go to any
team you be like what are like ask every
developer on a team five things that are
causing you friction in the code base or
things that you feel like we're we
should have changed a while ago
everybody can probably sit down with an
hour or two and make a good list of five
things will they all match I don't know
um but that might go into a technical
debt backlog and then there's kind of
Maintenance work that needs to happen so
you're building new features and
occasionally you need to go take care of
some like
overdue behind the scenes updates
refactorings
upgrades you know migrations is from one
search engine tool to some other you
know fulltech searching tool what
whatever the thing might be because it
doesn't it's no longer being supported
or it's you know it's going to be a
problem down the road so it it's kind of
like was not a super clear answer but
basically like you're kind of debt
financing getting things now yeah and
you are going to eventually have to pay
the piper so to speak and uh fix those
things if you want to have code that
continues to work one one thing that I
want to make sure everybody listening to
this realizes that that I think a lot of
people may take for granted
non-developers and developers who are
just getting into the field it's just
how quickly software starts to break
down there's a craft an important part
for teams to figure out how they're
going to
regularly it's like when you you build a
a a physical building and no one's kind
of confused about their needing to be
regular upkeep on it right and so I
think it's we talk about I want to have
this conversation with a lot of with
with our industry
because there are times where we build
things for whether you're you're working
on a part of a team or maybe if you work
at a company that's founded by probably
some people that understand software you
understand this but I work with a lot
I've worked with a lot of companies over
the years where they build something and
they're like What's the we need an
estimate buil to build this piece of
software and so someone built it for
them and then they're like great thank
you we got we need talk to you later and
then they're like hey there's a bug like
a month later like what do we do about
this there's a performance issue or this
weird Edge case so there's like regular
okay we need to spend money on we need
to invest time developer time into just
taking care of those types of requests
but they don't always realize that
there's all these other little things
behind the scenes that they're not
requesting or their users aren't
requesting but are just like hey look
there's new versions of things there's
security patches that have come out um
Apple has their own chipsets now and the
version of Ruby that we were running on
is no longer supported or no one's
compiled it yet for that and so if we
get a new our developers get new laptops
all of a sudden we can't spin up the
application we need to upgrade Ruby and
we need to patch things out in the
production servers what have you there's
security patches that need to get
deployed so all these like little things
that need to happen but your team needs
to have like a cohesive workflow for
regularly taking care of that stuff you
can automate some of that stuff now with
some tools but you need to take care of
that stuff and there's but there's still
a lot of things that are just more like
code Centric things that like oh we
designed it this way because that was
the pattern that was kind of invogue at
the time two years later we're now we're
starting to see that we're having to
work put a lot of workarounds because
it's not quite we didn't quite use it
the way we thought we would maybe we
need to revisit this part of the
application to simplify it or there's a
lot of companies that you know there's a
lot of conversations you know 10 years
ago about let's all move to microser
like you know let's break everything out
into lots of microservices because then
everything's kind of these bite-sized
pieces and it all fit together and it
won't matter if the microservice isn't
there our team is scaling like crazy
we're hiring 50 new Engineers every six
months that's what going to keep
happening so this will be the best way
to keep everything kind of scaling for
us and then fast forward 5 10 years and
they're like the team's now 20th of the
size and responsible for the amount of
microservices that a team that was four
times as big generated and they're like
this is too much for us to keep in our
head heads and what how do we manage all
this stuff and so that becomes a
maintenance problem and just like
thinking about as your the decisions
you're making at different points in the
life cycle of a software project can
come back and haunt you and and I want
to have those stories and let people
know that they're not alone that these
are common things and also to remind
people that most of software engineering
isn't getting to be there day one to
spin up the new application and get to
build the new features a lot of what
being a software engineer is maintenance
work making small up bug fixes figuring
out the quirky performance problem
trying to understand why something was
working in a really weird way retesting
things and so that's the conversation
I'm trying to have with guest on
maintainable awesome yeah it's a great
podcast and uh one question I had for
you is like just off the top of your
head for somebody who's totally new to
listening to the podcast who's been
doing software development for a while
wants to be learning more and thinking
more about maintainability of their code
and of their their company's codebase
and everything is there a particular
episode that just jumps out at you is
like oh this episode like I'm so proud
of this
episode you know it's a good question
thinking about a couple that come to
mind you know you know this is this
again this is over almost five years of
episodes 160 episodes yeah um so for
that sort of like early
on you know I'm thinking of Sandy Mets
oh yeah as is one was one of my favorite
conversations on there very famous rails
developer yeah and rubius and
objectoriented programmer and just like
hearing her talk about like oh I'll just
be in a in like a ruby object in a class
file in a ruby thing and she's like I
just start adding more classes to the
bottom of the page and I'm just like
what are you talking about um it was I
learned a lot from that conversation um
yeah that's one that quickly comes to
mind I'm include that uh link to that in
the show notes the video description on
YouTube uh everybody check that out I I
am also going to
include do my shell which is just this
fantastic article that you wrote many
years ago and and you actually came on
the free Cod cam podcast and read it uh
Episode
34 uh back in
2018 uh so like instead of trying to
drill deep into the story of Zell om my
Zell and uh the open source you know
boohemoth that you have set into motion
uh I'm going to encourage people to to
listen to that but one thing I do want
to talk to you about is the Synergy uh
you have this very popular uh one of the
most ubiquitously used certainly on Mac
uh tools uh command line tools and you
also have this podcast about
maintainability you of course have your
uh Robbie on Rails blog that you were
updating as of you know four or five
years ago um and and of course you've
got the consultancy planet argon and I
wanted to think about like how those
have those kind of like Voltron together
to create like the ultimate like lean
mean like Robbie Russell publicizing
machine over the years like like do
people come to you and like oh yeah I'm
a huge fan of om my Zell or I'm a fan of
the podcast like does that resting
client work for you
all you'd think you know I get this from
a lot of people and they they're
surprised to find out that it it doesn't
really I can't say that like a lot of my
clients probably give a or even
know what the hell om Zell is
occasionally I'll be on a call with a
client and they might have some
engineers and then they they they might
know who I am or know about omz shell um
and and so they'll come like oh I was
talking with some because it's usually
someone in like a different department
it's like I'm working with someone like
in
some logistical part of some company and
they're like this like this
manufacturing company and they have like
a fulfillment center and they're I'm
talking with someone there and they're
like hey we have this thing built with
rubby on RS blah blah blah you people
showed up in our Google searches and
seem to be reputable um so I feel like
we can talk about these things like I
also have a podcast or omell is another
thing so the thing that I I think it's
helped the most though is we do get ref
referrals you know we get referred from
peers in the industry so that does end
up being a way that we've gotten some of
our projects over the years um where it
might be Freelancers or some other
agencies that are deciding to no longer
be an agency or they maybe they got
acquired or interesting so if an agency
is going out of business so to speak
then they'll they'll kind of like pass
on their clients to you they try to like
help them help rehome them it's like a
natural thing like you want to if you
have a long relationship so sometimes
that they have like one or two big
clients and they're like well this is
something they've been working like we
have we had a client that came to us or
a company come to us a couple years ago
with a large client that they'd work
with for like 15 years um a couple
different Technologies but they
primarily use Rand rails and they're
like yeah like the owner of the company
had some health issues he's like I'm
retiring closing up shop and this isn't
like I want I want to put them in good
hands and you you seem like you can
probably carry them the next 10 years
can you be that company can we can we
trust that you they'll be in good hands
so that stuff that that occasionally
happens and so if you're running an
agency you think you're getting out of
the you know call plan Aron anyways uh
but as far as like that the the other
part of that the you know it was funny
this last year I went to um a conference
in where was it it was in Amsterdam
called rails world and I was there I was
I I I interviewed the rails core team
that hosted like a panel discussion like
an AMA thing that I I ran and I I I was
meeting people there that knew me for
omay Z shell and they're like why are
you at this
conference like why why rail it's
interesting so so like you got your om
my Zell like super user fans and then
you've got your rails blog fans from
back in the day and then you've probably
got lots of people who you just just
know you from your work argon right like
so it's almost like they're like three
different kinds of Robbie Russell fans
yeah only like connect the dots no they
don't connect the dots and so I was like
at the rails conference I'm passing out
omel stickers to people and I love that
I mean it's like and like a lot of
people like I didn't know you were a
ruby developer I didn't know like I'm
like I'm like I'm like oh Mya wouldn't
have existed if it wasn't for the ru and
rails Community like all of the original
ideas came from other
rubyists and I shared it with my Ruby on
Rails community and they shared it and
GitHub was written you know was written
with Ruby Ms and it was one of the first
big siiz project open source projects on
GitHub early on and it's all kind of
like connected in this weird way but
like you know fast forward 10 15 years
and actually yeah I think om Zell turns
15 years this September August or
something so which is wild to think of
that that's had its own lifespan but
it's not but it was it came out of like
a rubyan Real's developer working with
his co-workers and wanting to have some
consistent uh shortcuts and little
tricks up their sleeves to to improve
their their their efficiency and the
command line yeah yeah awesome well
congratulations on being able to
interview the rails score team by the
way that's a really cool
honor yeah
so we're getting toward the end of the
podcast we've been talking for a while
and we we've covered so much but I just
wanted to delve a little bit more into
your you know very interesting personal
life like I don't have a lot of guests
on here who are in a post rock band and
you know play guitar and do sets and
release albums and and they've been
doing that for a long time maybe you
could take a moment to just talk about
what post rock is uh for the uninitiated
and like what your particular band uh
how you all approach it and maybe what
the name means like a what is aula is it
just like like a place or oh um so the
band is named The Mighty moua Missoula
okay moua I didn't pronounce it
correctly it's a place right uh there's
a place called Missoula Montana in the
United States uh which is named after
something else uh as well so so first on
the name the the mighty Missoula is a
reference to many many many years ago
this before most of us were in on in
before there were a lot of humans there
trying to remember how many years I
forget how many years ago it was there
were a series of large floods that swept
across the Pacific Northwest and helped
carve out a lot of like the Columbia
Gorge which if anyone doesn't know but
the Columbia river goes Cuts between
Oregon and Washington and quite a bit of
Washington state is is like a massive um
River and so there were floods that were
basically started because there was this
uh glacial Lake in where where is now
like modern day like Montana where is
this huge glacial Lake and it like I
think it bursts through about 12 times
and just would flood all the way almost
all the way to the Pacific Ocean like
that's how massive of a lake it was that
it would just sweep across and so
drastically impacted the a substantial
portion of you know the United States
was underwater at this point flooded you
have any idea what like geological ERA
this was like double check it's the um
this was during during the end of the
last ice age okay so and so when so the
the band it's called The Mighty Missoula
and that's a reference to these floods
one of the ideas was like the Missoula
floods or something like that and we
thought that was too obvious so we went
with the mighty missula and people could
ask us what the name meant and we like
well there's these floods it's a GE
geology nerd type thing um because and
it kind of shaped the Pacific Northwest
um landscape quite a bit there's lots of
areas you can see where where the
flooding impacted there's debris and
like huge rocks in the middle of like
areas that do look like why is there a
huge Boulder that's like 50 feet tall
yeah how did I get there um because it
was it was a rock and a big flood anyhow
um the so the mighty miza is we're a
post rock band in like we're basically
we're instrumental kind of art rock band
and post rock is a genre of music that's
you know it's funny now it's like it was
trying to be not kind of break some of
the rules of standard rock music and try
to like let you you can just like drone
on about things and not have to follow a
lot of super consistent formulas for how
you write and produce your music it can
be more ethereal
atmospheric um I like to think about the
music that I listen to when I'm working
whether I'm writing code or I'm emailing
I don't like to listen to a lot of music
with vocals and so a lot of music that
resonated to me and like early on in my
you know think back it's funny music
ends up you know being this like thing
that you can connect to certain periods
of your life like um I
remember listening to like a lot of
Boards of Canada and which is not um
postrock but you know there was mostly
instrumental yeah similar drum stuff
qualities in terms of being something
you can kind of like listen to in the
background and it's yeah you know like
the ambient of the 1994 everybody called
that ambient back then right and then it
would just feel like I guess like Apex
Twin s ambient Works to ambient right
exactly and so there's so like bands in
that realm if you know couple of bands
like sear Ro is kind of considered a
post rock band um explosions of the sky
from you know from down in Texas where
you're at um MW Gods Speedy black
Emperor you know I was listening to a
lot of this stuff in there you know like
2001 2002 um got to see explosions of
this guy the very first time they played
at some small Club here in Portland
Oregon and I was in a goth rock band at
the time this was probably yeah maybe
3 and two or so and went to the small
club and saw them CU I found their music
on Napster or something and went to go
see them play and I remember thinking
they're a band without vocals how
interesting could that be and I went
there and I was like this was like one
of the most engaging shows I've ever
been to I was like just enamored by what
was happening how I felt with the music
and I was like and I was in a band that
didn't really like my singer all that
much and the drummer or the bass player
and I had talked about like it'd be cool
we always like when we're just jamming
on stuff before the rest of the band
gets there and we start working on our
music like like just noodling on things
like let's start our own project so I my
first post rock band was back then it
was called the vacant we did that for a
couple years and then Planet argon took
off and the Bas player she got pregnant
and our lives kind of went a different
direction and then so for years I wasn't
really playing music but um about I
think maybe going back like seven no
probably like nine years ago now I think
I was like looking at my equipment and
occasionally playing with my guitar I
was like I need to collaborate with
people
again and and so I didn't feel like I
was progressing personally by just
playing like I'm like oh I'll work on my
own music and right stuff I play a
couple different instrument I can't do
drums or anything but I can at least
make some interesting ambian type music
with guitar and some bass and stuff like
that and some synths and such but I was
like no I want to work on a project with
other people and like let's see what
comes out so posted out on
Craigslist you know found a drummer
found a bass player over appear time
start putting together a band we you
know we start writing some songs we pick
a name we record an EP and then our
drummer moves away for for journalism
school I have to find a new drummer and
then like he has different skill sets
can do a lot more recording stuff as
well we our skill set drastically
improves our WR songwriting evolves
write another album then the pandemic
happens we're stuck at home we during
the pandemic we were we our album
release so we printed vinyl we were
releasing our album April 2020 we were
planning like our you know launch show
you know album release made vinyl we
were super proud of this thing we're
like we're going to put together a tour
that
summer we're all stuck at home um okay
maybe not and so then during that
period we IID wanted to work on some
more ambient stuff like let's strip away
the drums our drummer can do a lot of s
and and soundscaping type stuff so like
we we all stuck at our home so we
decided we would make an ambient album
and we would pass files around the cloud
it was all cloud-based themed um so we
did that as a way to continue writing
together and build up some new skills
during that period and that way we knew
that when we got back together post
coming out of you the the next album
that we're working which we just
finished recording a month ago and we're
now in the the final mixing stages right
now so that'll be released sometime this
summer um so that was pretty exciting
and last year we got to go play a
festival in the postre f in Indianapolis
so we did a tour across the country to
that and back and played a lot of shows
with anywhere from four people in the
audience to you know several dozen you
know type of thing to playing at the
festival with like hundreds of people
there and that was pretty exciting but
yeah it was it I'm kind of I kind of
look at it as like it's it's a hobby I'm
not this isn't going to be my career by
any
means who knows but it's kind of like a
little bit feels like cosplay sometimes
um like it's like we're banned we're
we're doing this fun stuff but like it's
a fun hobby and and it keeps me you know
out of the house a couple days a week to
go work with other people on and it's
not my project it's our project I might
have posted the original Craigslist ad
and so I think in some ways I'm like the
leader a little bit I have that project
management skill set but I'm not but
it's our band it's like yeah do you ever
have to like kind of like suppress your
manager I mean you're a CEO so like
you're used to like figuring out what
needs to be done and like listening to
everybody's opinions and then making a
decision and people are expecting to go
along with it that that doesn't really
work in your band though right like is
it more democratic or or are you
somewhat autocratic it is it's it's a
lot more democratic sometimes we'll have
conversations like who cares the most
about this particular decision there's
you know I gu like our our drummer I
mentioned has like a lot more he went to
school and he has a background in in uh
Sound Engineering so like things on that
realm we kind of defer to him to help
make a lot of decisions and kind of
guide us and teach us through it but he
also has a really good knack for being a
good producer which is you know and and
that's and someone that can help unblock
us or help like when you're recording
something in front of other people and
you're trying to figure it out it's like
I think I think about music I think
everybody has this idea that you write
the music and it's all perfect and
you're going to play it the same way
every single time and it's like that's
not what happens I just watched Quincy
do the uh intro song like three times um
and they all sound a little bit they all
sounded great three different times um
different ways and that's that's the way
it works so like sometimes you're kind
of like you don't remember how you did
something or it doesn't quite feel the
same when you actually go to record it
and and like someone has an idea like no
do it the way you did it originally and
you're like I don't and there's there's
a performance aspect as well it's like
sometimes I want to play the Baseline
just like it was on the record but maybe
mechanically like I get tripped up by
some sort of like jump or something like
that yeah and uh yeah so can't reproduce
everything and yeah you don't
necessarily want to that's why people
are you know still bootlegging grateful
Day concerts uh I mean how many concerts
have they done and there's probably a
recording of pretty much every single
recording and fans will listen to all
the different versions of like very
similar kind of like I guess and jazz is
an entire art based around the notion of
having like kind of like a motif if you
will and then like diving into you know
jamming
essentially it's true the um
it's just that's the thing about so to
answer your question yeah I don't feel
like I have to put my CEO in hat very
often I mean I'm usually the one that's
like over looking finances for the band
and like dealing with some of like the
the paperwork when we're negotiating
some stuff for like a a festival or
shows or something like that but um but
otherwise yeah everything else is very
collaborative and and and I kind of like
let them drive a lot more of some of the
songw writing I might have like some
guitar ideas I have and but they're
definitely I'm surrounded myself with
people that are much better musicians
and so I get to kind of grow with them
which is a thing that I appreciate about
like the types of projects that I do
like you mentioned omell the thing about
omell it's like I might have planted
this flag once upon a time that here's
this kind of concept and the structure I
have and then and immediately I was like
please contribute and now we've had over
2,000 people contribute code to the
project and so I'm just like it's it's
become what it is because of the people
that decided they wanted to participate
and they felt like they could and maybe
I made it easier for people to
contribute in some way or at least made
it inviting and that that's helped you
know after we finish this I'm going to
hop over to an omell maintainer meeting
with the two other people that help
maintain the project and I've never met
them in person yet actually hoping to do
that in a few months actually um but
it's just like I I just Sur and that's
why I don't I didn't like being a
consultant an early era Contracting
thing you know outside of my you know I
mentioned my partner that was a designer
we would work collaboratively but I
didn't really get to feel like I was up
leveling as a developer because I wasn't
really working with a lot of other peer
developers very often just kind of like
figuring things out myself and so I felt
like I've excelled the more that I've
leaned into working on projects that
involved other people to help get the
thing done and other skill sets people
that were better programmers or deeper
programmers in certain things and there
was Project managers and there was a
designer and there's and the
collaborative aspect of working with the
client or other people to bounce ideas
off of and like to review my code or for
me to review someone else's
code that's that's the world I like to
live in and so like we'll talk to a lot
of people that are
Freelancers and I'm like I don't
understand that that world like how
you've decided that that's the thing you
want to do I'm like what's wrong with
you why don't you trust people U I'm
kind of jokingly saying that and and
it's like but what what is it that
you're like I want to just go do my own
thing and maybe and that's like an
interesting thing for me to wrap my head
around because that doesn't make sense
to my brain but I um so even though I
thought I wanted to DIY it it was always
about like I wanted to do my thing but I
didn't think that it was going to become
this thing with employees as soon as I
had that around me I was like oh how
could I do this any other way this is
way better yeah well so to some extent
your DIY spirit is like a victim of his
own
success a little bit Yeah Yeah well uh I
just have one closing question uh
because you know Portland seems to be
like a really key aspect of your life
you know you chose to move there you've
stayed there much longer than I've ever
lived in any one city um
and if somebody's going to Portland for
the first
time what is something they hands down
should
consider taking a day to
do if they're
able-bodied to leave Portland and go out
to the gorge and go on some hikes or a
hike somewhere there's a couple great gr
hikes feel free to write me I'll give
you a list of a couple things depending
on your I would say your ability to
threshold of how much pain you want to
endure or not um so that I mean there
really like so much of like the thing I
love about Portland is so close like 30
minutes away and you can be hiking in
some pretty gorgeous areas
um reminds me that early on there was a
rails conference we we we shuttled a
couple buses we rented some bus charter
buses and we took a bunch of Ruby on
Rails developers hiking one afternoon as
a way to like let's go do this and like
let's show you outside but if you're in
Portland one thing that I would do like
inside the city is honestly I think just
like you know it's like cliche to like
talk about if I like wandering the
coffee roasies and getting to check out
different coffee shops and stuff like
that something I enjoy doing in any City
so maybe it's I feel like that was more
of a thing more of a Portland thing
early in the air and so I still think
about that which kind of just got me
excited when every time I travel now I'm
like I want to go find the coffee
roaster STS and try coffee but that was
more I feel like that still leans on
being kind of slightly more of a
Portland origin type of thing so I think
checking out some of those old coffee
roasteries is a thing and is there a
specific
Street a specific Street where like a
lot of them are collocated or no they
they're all kind of around now um like
the what ends up happening is like the
places that are on the
the more popular streets they might turn
into chains and
then it depends like I don't want people
to judge me because I'm like oh Haw ha's
ha's still cute um but I'm like actually
I don't know if any of the roasteries
there are the like actual roasteries
over there right now so they're all kind
of like scattered a little bit okay but
Hawthorne is like a destination that a
lot of people might like if you're a
total Portland novice and you're just
looking for a single word remember
Hawthorne it sounds like is uh get hop
in the the taxi take me to Uber uh take
take me to Hawthorne and stuff on it
right exactly that and Andor uh and then
hit the pals on Hawthorne but if you
have time go downtown and go to the big
PALS like that's still our our
independent bookstore there is PALS huge
so definitely spend hours there awesome
well Robbie it has been an honor to have
you on the podcast again everybody who's
listening to this be sure to check out
Rob reading of uh his St my Zell uh
article uh which I'm linking to in the
show notes also check out that Sandy
Mets episode of maintainable and uh I'm
going to also link to one of your recent
live sets that I found on YouTube uh
from the mighty
Missoula um and uh yeah thank you so
much for coming on thank you for
maintaining om my Z shell which like I
think most of the people on pream team
use it probably on a daily basis um and
uh thank you again for just being so so
giving of your wisdom from running a
consultancy the past 22 years and all
the lessons you've learned and being so
candid this is really means a lot
because people can this is like the
unvarnished like implementation details
of running a to right yes I don't have a
uh I don't have a a publicist to help me
figure out how to better frame my
narrative and thank you Quincy thanks
for having me on thanks for everything
that you and code Camp are doing um
thanks for introducing for being part of
the reason why I've met such a good
friend here in Portland Abby through
Abby editor for free code Camp uh you've
almost certainly seen her work even if
you haven't directly read an article by
her I need to pick up that book uh
getting things done as well I'm excited
about that new book on freeo Camp press
check it out uh Omar rosenbom wrote he
he is a git Enthusiast to say the least
he writes like a 300 page book on git so
that's wonderful check that out
yeah until next week everybody happy
coding